[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radiofrance internacional y de France
24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
Centroamérica y su difícil proceso de
integración para ello nos acompañan en
este estudio tres invitados ya les
presento a Pascal Dúo analista
especialista en Centroamérica
corresponsal del diario de hoy
bienvenido Muchas gracias
encargado de la misión para
Centroamérica de la ong ssd Tech
solidaridad bienvenido llull Gracias y
Logan paguettes geógrafo docente en la
universidad parisite bienvenido Gracias
la integración en Centroamérica en
nuestro asunto en Primera Plana
[Música]
la integración en Centroamérica no es
asunto fácil cierto es que desde los
años 90 se han ido realizando progresos
considerables pero una batería de crisis
seguidas como las de Nicaragua la
migratoria y también la sanitaria
provocada por la pandemia de la covid
han puesto demasiados obstáculos en el
camino Cómo re dinamizar esa integración
que parece básica para enfrentar retos
conjuntos en un contexto en el que
crecen las voces que llaman la atención
sobre el aumento del autoritarismo en la
región el régimen de Ortega Nicaragua el
nuevo modelo tan popular como polémico
de bukele en El Salvador olas de
persecución a la justicia en Guatemala y
en general a la libertad de información
en la región son algunas de las
múltiples realidades que conforman una
región complicada que necesita voluntad
política y liderazgo para avanzar en
este proceso de integración repasemos lo
que dice la prensa al respecto en
Centroamérica asistimos al resurgir del
autoritarismo y ojalá no se extienda
alerta Claudia paz y paz la la primera
mujer que ocupó el cargo de fiscal
general en Guatemala en esta entrevista
que recoge el diario el tiempo el faro
Costa Rica malas señales en el remanso
centroamericano de la libertad de prensa
el presidente Rodrigo Chávez afianza su
discurso ofensivo contra los medios y
América squater League señala que crece
la lista de admiradores de bukele por
toda latinoamérica bueno Pascal desde
los años 90 se intentaba avanzar en la
integración Pero ha habido como decía
muchos obstáculos por las sucesivas
crisis Cómo ha sido la historia de la
integración en la región y en qué punto
nos encontramos ahora pues hoy en día
estamos en el cruce de camino pero es
cierto que la integración de
Centroamérica Tuvo una dinámica al
principio de los años 90 el protocolo de
Tegucigalpa en 91 ha creado el zika el
sistema de integración centroamericano
saliendo de esos años de conflictos
internos en Centroamérica
en este esquema este oeste de los años
80 y por cierto la integración
centroamericana aparecía como una
ilusión como un sueño Un sueño de paz un
sueño de prosperidad y así fue en los 90
con una institucionalidad que permitió
que estableció lazos con la Unión
Europea con los Estados Unidos con una
dinámica económica en los 2000 y por
cierto hoy en día estamos en un cruce de
camino porque temas sociales que lleven
tanto sobre la seguridad como temas
sobre la salud la alimentación los temas
migratorios han nutrido una forma de
fragmentación regional Y definitivamente
el desafío hoy en día es reencontrar un
hilo mínimo común luego vamos a explorar
ese hilo mínimo común
en una región azotada a menudo por la
violencia y las crisis políticas desde
organizaciones como la suya se tiene la
convicción de que avanzar en la
integración supondría
desarrollo y mejores estándares
democráticos
vincular desarrollo y gobernanza
democrática porque en la región cuando
se habla de Progreso económico hay que
ver que es una región marcada por
extremas desigualdades con unos índices
de pobreza alta pobreza diversión
infantil de los peores del mundo y eso
es debido a un modelo extractivista
basado sobre la explotación sin límite
de respuesta naturales para exportación
y que solamente se beneficia a unos
pocos sin tomar en cuenta las
necesidades básicas de las propias de
las poblaciones locales entonces ahí se
ve un vínculo fuerte entre un modelo que
genera esos conflictos socioambientales
que aumenta la pobreza y que va a hacer
aumentar también esas desigualdades
Entonces está todo vinculado y ya quiere
pensar un poco el modelo dominante
económico en la región en este momento
podríamos hablar más de quizá de
contagio y de consideración del modelo
bukele que desde afuera es más
criticable digamos pero que es popular y
tentador para que otros sigan sus pasos
es una tendencia Logan en Centroamérica
lo podemos ver como una tendencia que se
expanda futuro
puede ser sí lo importante de lo que mis
colegas señalan es este dinámica de
fragmentación histórica en esta región y
los intentos de integración regional No
quedan desde los años 90 habían sido una
una perspectiva interesante hoy en día
creo que el interés político para la
integración tanto Interamericana ha
bajado mucho dentro de los estados que
conforman la región no Y eso es un mundo
muy importante el deseo no la necesidad
de lograr una integración ya no está en
la mesa y desde hace varios Este
gobiernos
no le conviene a un bukele por ejemplo
no le conviene a muchos de los líderes
actuales en Centroamérica porque más
integración de regional significa más
control sobre las instituciones
nacionales no sobre el derecho a una
justicia en muchos casos sobre la la
construcción de un estado de derecho que
hace falta como lo decía que es una una
situación muy crítica hoy en día en en
Centroamérica y de ahí la multiplicación
de crisis que vemos no Y la dificultad
de responder a nivel regional a esas
crisis volvemos al nivel nacional donde
cada quien Busca su propio camino
quieres Añadir algo más Sí por supuesto
es muy popular en El Salvador y toda la
derecha de América Latina están mirando
para él es el hombre del momento pero lo
que pasa es que todavía no sabemos Cuál
es el costo real de esa guerra contra
las maras de esa Paz entre comillas en
términos de Justicia social se está
hablando desde algunos estudios de ong
que las megas cárceles son campos de
concentración donde los
las personas encarceladas son detenidos
en condiciones infrahumanas y todavía
sin ningún juzgamiento es una sociedad
donde una policía puede arrestar y tener
sin pruebas donde un fiscal puede acusar
sin pruebas donde un juez puede con una
sin pruebas entonces a largo plazo tiene
resultado y es un alivio para la
población pero todavía no sabemos Cuál
va a ser el costo real a lo largo plazo
claro la pregunta quizás sería si esa
vulneración de Derechos Humanos que
implica el modelo bukele es el precio
aceptado socialmente por los ciudadanos
para combatir la inseguridad que llevan
años padeciendo y soportando es decir
claro es contra los Derechos Humanos
pero lo que soportan los ciudadanos de
12 años también es contra los Derechos
Humanos es que hay que ponerse en la
piel para entender
diría Sí y eso es una ilustración de la
problemática pero definitivamente la
temática de la inseguridad viene de
lejos viene de los años 90 viene de esta
correlación con los Estados Unidos donde
grupos
usted sabemos que hay un comunidades
centroamericanas muy importantes en
Centroamérica Pero había delincuentes y
en los Estados Unidos se les devolvieron
en Centroamérica si les devolvieron en
El Salvador y y demás países y ahí
obviamente se constituyeron para llegar
a ser lo que llamamos hoy en día las
barras Pero eso viene desde más de 25
años y nutró alimentó una forma de
desilusión del esquema democrático que
era pegado a la noción de integración
saliendo de los años de guerra Eso es
enrico para entender lo que está pasando
Entonces definitivamente hablando de
Salvador y y y sabemos que este país
tenía tasa de homicidios de los más
elevados estábamos a 100 homicidios al
año por cien mil en 2015 y 2016 era el
tema céntrico Social para la población y
hoy en día definitivamente
haberse atacado en una forma en una
guerra contra las barras en una mecánica
de guerra definitivamente
a generar una satisfacción de la
población porque hoy en día se siente
más segura y esa seguridad la perciben
como un instrumento para un nuevo
reimpulso económico porque no olvidemos
que Centroamérica es la región
centroamericana es la cuarta o la quinta
economía de América Latina
es interesante lo que lo que se plantea
efectivamente ese ese esa necesidad de
seguridad la población lo vive como un
alivio o lo cuando hay esas esos métodos
de autoridad pero al mismo tiempo es una
vulnerabilidad para muchas poblaciones
fuera de los contextos de las maras o
fuera de los contextos de los
narcotraficantes de los que podemos
hablar también porque la importancia del
narcotráfico en la zona en los últimos
diez años es muy importante y el peligro
es un peligro de una violencia por parte
del Estado que viene como una nueva
forma de vulnerabilidad en una región
donde hay muchas vulnerabilidades pero
este miedo a la forma de actuar del
gobierno puede llevar a otra inseguridad
una inseguridad que también lleva a
emigrar que lleva a buscar otras formas
está la población está en contra de la
violencia por parte de maras o otros por
un lado y la violencia de estado por
otro lado entonces la perspectiva es
difícil la crisis migratoria pone al
triángulo Norte en una posición delicada
con México y Estados Unidos que han
propuesto varios mecanismos de ayuda
para mantener a la población en sus
países y gestionar los otros flujos no
sé si esta situación frena proyectos de
integración si se plantea la protección
de los migrantes
pues la política planteada por los
Estados Unidos y México es totalmente de
saborizante de los persas migrantes Yo
quiero insistir en que los Estados
Unidos consiguieron hacer una
externalización de la política
migratoria o sea México se ha vuelto una
frontera para los que vienen de
Guatemala Guatemala funciona para los
que vienen del sur y etcétera bajo la
condicionalidad de recibir ayuda al
desarrollo de plantearse en los acuerdos
de comercio con los Estados Unidos es
decir la concepción de patio trasero que
siempre está dicho sigue siendo Sigue
estando ahí Es decir con biden no ha
cambiado esa concepción de patio trasero
de Estados Unidos de Centroamérica la
condición de Centroamérica para nada y
el muro así lucen los mexicanos no está
en la frontera norte pero en la frontera
sur y entonces hay todo ese mecanismo de
detención y depredación de libertad que
va totalmente contrario al proyecto de
integración justamente
y precisamente externalización de
fronteras no que es el proceso que vemos
desde hace 15 años fue primero de
Estados Unidos hacia México hoy en día
va desde México a Guatemala estoy muy de
acuerdo que hay como un efecto no de de
países hacia otros países pero también
con una relación con Estados Unidos y
con México en Centroamérica que es muy
delicada porque se trata de utilizar
instrumentalizar al tema migratorio en
otros asuntos no el asunto de defensa
nacional por parte de Estados Unidos el
asunto de la condicionalidad del apoyo
al desarrollo para México por ejemplo
pero también para Estados Unidos es
decir que el tema migratorio es una
variable de ajuste en muchos otros
aspectos no de la de la de esa región
Entonces yo no creo que haya una
búsqueda real por parte de los estados
de Centroamérica de una solución al
problema migratorio más bien hay una
búsqueda de acuerdos un acuerdo
estructural no un acuerdo
coyuntural no que permiten en algún
momento
lidiar con la situación no más y todo
esto con la perspectiva de procesos
electorales tanto en México como en
Estados Unidos vamos a hablar de ello la
vuelta también de la libertad de
expresión y de también preocupante
signos en países que hasta ahora se
podían considerar como un poco más al
margen como era el caso de Costa Rica
vas a la vuelta de pausa
Enlace del cono Sur a Norteamérica de
los Andes a Centroamérica una cita
semanal con los temas más importantes de
los países del continente americano
presentada por los corresponsales de
France 24
enlace en France 24 y France 24.com
en France 24 punto com siga nuestra
transmisión en vivo
encuentre toda la información que
necesita
noticias en directo las 24 horas del día
y en cuatro idiomas
informese sobre los temas que le
interesan
Busca la actualidad o la repetición de
una emisión
conéctese
a un clic la información internacional
en directo
libertad
seguimos en Primera Plana esta semana
hablando de la integración en
Centroamérica lo hacemos con el analista
Pascal duró con el geógrafo Logan pague
y con el encargado de la misión para
Centroamérica de la ong
hablamos antes de la pausa de Estados
Unidos de los flujos migratorios Pero
quizás debemos también hablar Bueno de
esos actores terceros actores que tienen
una influencia especial en Centroamérica
caso de Taiwán el caso de Rusia el caso
de China los juegos internacionales en
Centroamérica no alientan un trabajo
regional sin hablar del papel del crimen
organizado Pascal su situación de
sándwich le deja poco margen de maniobra
cómo cómo actúan las influencias de esos
actores en la región Pues creo que
estamos en un momento clave hoy en día
dado las circunstancias internacionales
centro rica es lo dijiste muy bien en
una región clave entre el norte el sur
pero dando hacia el Pacífico teniendo
relación con Asia tanto como el
Atlántico y Europa
miremos pero los principales socios en
términos de exportación de Centroamérica
quedan siendo los Estados Unidos la
Unión Europea y Centroamérica china está
por 4% todavía
en términos de exportación pero dado esa
fragmentación política tenemos unos
países que obviamente
aprovechan para
construir una forma de alternativa
internacional pienso obviamente
Nicaragua donde estuvo en estos días el
presidente de Irán donde vino el
canciller ruso labrof son signos muy
fuertes que por supuesto tienen
consecuencia
el esquema Regional de una política
exterior común porque la integración
significa también un un una figura una
acción una dinámica hacia el exterior y
que no fuese solamente hacia el norte y
hacia Europa ahora veo que la la
presidenta de la comisión
está esta semana y estuvo esos días en
Latinoamérica
Brasil Argentina México para impulsar
una nueva presencia Por qué Porque hoy
en día Centroamérica y todo está ligado
la temática de la migración la temática
de seguridad Está frente a su propia
responsabilidad
histórica y entiende que no solamente
eso no tiene que contar con la comunidad
internacional y eso es también una
evolución importante lo internacional
fue considerado como un socio amigable
de la reconstrucción y de la dinámica de
Centroamérica los 90 los
hasta el principio 2017 hoy en día
Centroamérica este frente a sus propios
desafíos pero que sí tienen una
consecuencia internacional Sí yo creo
que hay nuevo escenario diplomático y
político y que se ve también en las
instancias internacionales por ejemplo
en la última sesión del Consejo de
Derechos Humanos de las Naciones Unidas
en Ginebra cuando se tocó el tema de
Nicaragua me sorprendido muchísimo que
hubo todo un grupo de estado encabezado
por China y rusa y con Venezuela y Cuba
Para apoyar a Nicaragua frente al
informe que ha hecho por un grupo de
experto que dijeron que era el crimen de
lesa humanidad pero esos grupos y sobre
todo rusa y China insistieron para esa
que era una violación alzar la soledad
internacional que era una injerencia que
era una manipulación el imperialismo de
parte del occidente Entonces se ve que
hay esa transformación y que parece
salir de otro momento del momento de la
Guerra Fría literalmente y que aquí
centro de América está en el entorno de
este juego de al nivel de diferentes
papeles internacionales la Unión Europea
quiere revitalizar sus vínculos con la
región tras alarmarse del terreno
conquistado por actores como Rusia o
china Aunque bueno Pascal de
relativizado un poco esos datos por
ejemplo de China a partir del 1 de Julio
lo hará Especialmente con la presidencia
rotatoria que tomará España no sé Logan
el apoyo a la sociedad civil a las
fuerzas democráticas a contrapoderes
como la libertad de prensa por dónde
debe ir ese papel de la Unión Europea en
la región yo creo que la Unión Europea y
otras instituciones digamos de este
nivel mundial no que tenga esa capacidad
global tienen que tener mucha vigilancia
no en la manera en el cual los Derechos
Humanos
están en la mesa no solamente en Sí en
forma general pero el derecho de la
información o la libertad de prensa que
está muy en peligro la defensa hacia los
que luchan por medio ambiente la
cantidad no de asesinatos que hay de
Defensores de medio ambiente en
Centroamérica no es asombrosa también la
social civil de manera general a través
de esos temas o esos asuntos de género
por ejemplo de defensa de género de
defensa de los menores de la posibilidad
de emigrar de vivir afuera y de mantener
relación con su país de origen no todas
esas dimensiones de derechos y esas
dimensiones democratía no como se puede
esperar de cualquier país creo que la
Unión Europea y otros tienen que de
mucha vigilancia y no conceder acuerdos
que muchas veces Son acuerdos
comerciales con intereses y lo vemos no
en el caso de Rusia en el caso de tahuán
por ejemplo en Guatemala Son acuerdos
económicos y el casta el casta 2004 es
un acuerdo regional no de libre comercio
por motivos de negocios o de
intercambios económicos
pasamos por encima no digamos de muchos
derechos o de mucho respeto la real
política la economía que se lleva por
delante de los Derechos Humanos Pues tú
nunca pasa No es que es irónico es
irónico siempre pasa estamos a poco de
las elecciones en Guatemala se notan ya
los mismos patrones que han
caracterizado las últimas elecciones en
la región Pascal
Pues por hacer el punto de Guatemala
porque como sí tenemos selecciones ya en
perspectiva sí tienen la primera vuelta
de la presidencial está ya por por
llegar definitivamente Pues de los
principales candidatos aparece su ríos
de la alianza valor unionista Sandra
Torres que había sido primera dama
siendo la esposa de Álvaro Colón al
final de 2000 de 2008 hasta el 2011 y
que es del partido cabal centro entonces
ahí Creo que una de las sorpresas en
términos de movilización y de influencia
llegará de las alcaldías va a llegar del
justamente de este tejido municipal
territorial en Guatemala ahora Guatemala
es muy interesante Por qué Porque cuando
hablamos de la región y de esas
interferencias internacional
debemos olvidar lo esencial y no debemos
verlo como occidentales veámoslo desde
el terreno centroamericano El problema
es que los estados hoy en día deben
redimiar Buscar sus fuentes Fiscales
para tener los medios de su política es
decir que la temática de seguridad
dentro de de barrios que ya en término
de imagen tiene consecuencia regional es
una ilustración de búsqueda también de
una forma de saneamiento digamos para
buscando una una nueva un nuevo hilo que
es común a los países es decir que
Centroamérica hoy en día está buscándose
un nuevo modelo con el cual van a poder
reinventar una integración que hoy en
día están como haber fallecido
porque se me hace un poco difícil de
calificar esas elecciones de libres sí
miramos todo el proceso de registro de
candidaturas hay una gran de
permisividad por un lado por el por la
candidatura de
sur y ríos por ejemplo que no podría
normalmente conectarse porque es hija
del dictador Efraín monté y una
exclusión de otras candidaturas como del
movimiento de liberación de los pueblos
entonces y Para cerrar con el tema de la
Unión Europea que va a mandar una misión
de observación electoral solamente el
día de la votación y que con certeza nos
va a calificar las elecciones de libres
pero no van a tomar en cuenta todo lo
que aconteció desde un año antes y de la
criminalización de la sociedad civil que
no pudo hacer campaña para una votación
libre y todo se parece muy restringido
entonces ahí Parece que son las peores
elecciones desde décadas en Guatemala
hablemos de instrumentos para
integración en los minutos que nos
quedan como el zika el sistema de
integración en Centroamérica la
presencia ahora la tiene El Salvador
hasta final de año que es el modelo
referente en la lucha contra la
delincuencia para otros muchos que lo
están observando en la región Este
modelo puede ser preconizado para
relanzar la integración con la
presidencia del Salvador es una pregunta
que les quiero plantear Logan
sí obviamente yo creo que la necesidad
de avanzar en esta integración y lo que
lo que es el zika el sí que ha logrado
resultados no digamos tampoco que no ha
funcionado desde los años 90 en términos
por ejemplo de energía de interconexión
de sistemas energéticos
el zika es un es un paso adelante el
problema hoy en día es la voluntad
política de cada gobierno de
involucrarse en el zika yo creo que
incluso en cada país pueden ver al zika
como un peligro porque es un peligro de
control de lo que está pasando al nivel
de los gobiernos no y tiene que ver con
impunidad con corrupción que son temas
que el zika quiere quiere abarcar pero
de otra forma No entonces hay una hay un
momento político estoy de acuerdo con
Pascal bueno dice que es un momento
particular Pero también es un momento
que se parece a otros anteriores no
donde la la integración regional Sí pero
con el límite de que no vengas a mirar
lo que pasa en mi casa claro El Salvador
quiere poner el acento en la inseguridad
como base para relanzar esa integración
está bien hecho el diagnóstico de atajar
en primer lugar ese punto sin esa base
previa no puede llegar la prosperidad o
el desarrollo Pascal Pues eso
definitivamente
tampoco Es solamente eso es un también
regional
el aeropuerto Cuántos aeropuertos en
Centroamérica Cuántos viajeros más de 31
millones sobre una población de por
ejemplo es Centroamérica es exportador
de los servicios hace parte de los
primeros exportadores mundiales de de
productos alimentarios como la piña como
el café como el plátano la hormona bueno
eso también es Centroamérica
hoy en día definitivamente porque hubo
una desilusión sobre el sistema
democrático que parecía exportado
justamente saliendo de Las Guerras de
los 80 hoy en día definitivamente parece
que el sistema
liberal democrático que fue instituido
esos dos diseños
favoreció Esa esa emergencia de una
delincuencia que volvió central a nivel
social entiendo lo que dice por supuesto
sobre la temática por ejemplo de los
indígenas lo que toca
mucho por Guatemala pero también fue
Centroamérica tiene figuras Rigoberta
menchú el premio Nobel de la paz desde
92 Pues nos quedamos con esas figuras
íntimo para más Pero ha sido un placer
compartir este tiempo con ustedes
y a todos ustedes nos vemos aquí en
Primera Plana la próxima semana Muchas
gracias
[Música]